son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito y lima continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna seguimos
comentando lees los principales hechos
del día les agradecemos su sintonía y
vamos con los titulares de esta jornada
durante el inicio de las audiencias de
la comisión del congreso de eeuu que
investiga y debate el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 el
presidente del comité señaló que el
ataque fue un intento de golpe que puso
en riesgo dos siglos y medio de
democracia constitucional tenemos
reporte desde washington
en su primer discurso ante la plenaria
de jefes de estado y gobierno en la
cumbre de las américas el presidente
estadounidense joe biden resaltó la
importancia de defender la democracia en
el continente el mandatario argentino
alberto fernández criticó los vetos de
washington a cuba nicaragua y venezuela
miles de argentinos protestaron en las
calles de buenos aires en contra de las
medidas económicas justamente del
presidente alberto fernández los
ciudadanos piden al ejecutivo que
garantice el acceso al trabajo informal
y condenan el préstamo con el fondo
monetario internacional cuyo primer
desembolso se realizó el miércoles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
iniciamos en eeuu donde hay expectativa
pues ya iniciaron las audiencias del
comité del congreso que investiga el
ataque al capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 cuando una turba de seguidores del
ex presidente de donald trump irrumpió
en el edificio el asalto dejó cinco
personas fallecidas conectamos con
cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de france
24 en washington que tiene todos los
detalles
cristóbal hasta ahora que han dicho en
esta audiencia
empezó a las 8 de la noche en punto de
washington y la primera en hablar fue la
representante de la cámara dice jane y
ella es de wyoming ella es una de las
dos republicanas que hace parte del
comité que investiga lo que pasó el 6 de
enero del 2021 una de las dos únicos
republicanos que hace parte de este
comité ella dijo que
básicamente las pruebas que se están
presentando muestran que trump estuvo en
el centro de los esfuerzos para
desconocer los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales pasadas dio y
puso vídeos de republicanos de
familiares y de allegados al gobierno y
asesores y personas que hicieron parte
del gobierno de donald trump ellos
mismos diciendo como no había pruebas
suficientes para desconocer los
resultados electorales de las elecciones
del 2020 entre los que pusieron en vídeo
estuvo el fiscal el ex fiscal general
william ward que decía en repetidas
ocasiones que le dijo al presidente de
trump que no había pruebas suficientes
su hija ivanka trump estuvo también en
vídeo en estas pruebas que está
presentando liz cheney diciendo que
efectivamente ha apoyado al fiscal
general y otros otros asesores más
también diciendo que no había pruebas
para el argumento de fraude electoral
cristóbal justamente uno de los puntos a
determinar en estas audiencias es la
responsabilidad o no del presidente el
ex presidente de donald trump en estos
hechos qué posibilidades reales hay de
que el ex mandatario sea declarado
culpable
pues se dice que están presentando y que
van a presentar vídeos que nunca antes
se han visto pruebas que nunca antes se
habían revelado y que en total se
calcula que serán cerca de 8 audiencias
donde se presentarán todo tipo de
argumentos para probar precisamente la
responsabilidad del otro pero al final
será el departamento de justicia el que
termine tomando una acción legal frente
al ex presidente lo que puede hacer la
cama de representantes y el congreso
simplemente es presentar toda la
evidencia que ha recogido por más de un
año cristóbal a usted muchas gracias por
esta ampliación estaremos muy pendientes
de lo que ocurra en estas audiencias y
en la ciudad de los ángeles también en
eeuu se llevó a cabo la cuarta jornada
de la cumbre de las américas en su
discurso inaugural ante la plenaria de
la cumbre vaivén abogó por un continente
donde se defienda la democracia y se
proteja el medio ambiente por su parte
el jefe de estado argentino alberto
fernández condenó los vetos de
washington a cuba nicaragua y venezuela
que no fueron invitados al encuentro
definitivamente hubiésemos querido otra
cumbre de las américas el silencio de
los ausentes nos interpela
para que esto no vuelva a suceder
y that quisiera dejar sentado para el
futuro que el hecho de ser país
anfitrión de la cumbre no otorga la
capacidad de imponer el derecho de
admisión sobre los países miembros del
continente el diálogo en la diversidad
es el mejor instrumento para promover la
democracia y la lucha contra la
desigualdad la multitudinaria caravana
migrante que partió el lunes desde
tapachula en el sur de méxico continúa
su avance hacia el norte del país tras
pasar la noche en la localidad de
huixtla donde muchos de los integrantes
lograron obtener sus documentos legales
para el tránsito los miles de migrantes
se dividieron en cuatro grupos desde la
zona andrés suárez enviado especial de
france 24 nos amplió la información
la caravana de miles de emigrantes se
encuentra en este momento fragmentada en
diferentes puntos de huixtla al sur de
méxico nos encontramos en uno de ellos
un polideportivo donde los migrantes
pernoctan a la espera de resolver su
estatus migratorio pero en huixtla a
diferencia de tapachula los migrantes y
han encontrado mayor recepción y
diligencia de parte de las oficinas de
aduana de entregarles los formatos
múltiples de emigración que los blindan
por 30 días de ser capturados y
deportados a sus países de origen
obtenido de este visado una gran parte
de los migrantes con los que hemos
conversado continuará su camino a pie
pero muchos otros saldrán en buses desde
aquí de huixtla hasta ciudad de mexico
posteriormente a la frontera sur de los
eeuu en específico al borde limítrofe
con texas donde les han dicho que el
caudal del río bravo es bajo esta llega
hasta las rodillas y es mucho más fácil
para ellos cruzar los de una manera
ilegal en otras noticias este jueves los
argentinos salieron a las calles de
buenos aires para pedir condiciones de
vida dignas de la gran tasa de pobreza e
inflación del país que ahora acaba de
refinanciar una deuda con el fondo
monetario internacional- prioridades por
encima del bienestar de la población
según lo que denuncian sectores de
izquierda
alva santana nos amplía
es un descontento que parece no cesar a
medida que los niveles de pobreza y las
condiciones de vida precarias se
mantienen en argentina la población
exige acciones por parte del gobierno
una demanda con la que los argentinos
inundaron las calles de buenos aires
estamos acá lo mismo que marchamos en el
país hace un mes que es por trabajo
genuino contra la pobreza y el hambre
no hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de
poder la marcha federal tuvimos
diferentes reuniones con el gobierno la
verdad que fueron todas insatisfactoria
y es que en el país que roza el 60 por
ciento de inflación anual mucha gente
está aguantando hambre como dicen los
argentinos con una tasa de pobreza del
más del 37 por ciento los ciudadanos
exigen una mayor asistencia a los
comedores sociales y a las familias
mientras los precios de los alimentos y
otros productos básicos siguen
aumentando
[Música]
400 millones de personas
47 millones
en
una precariedad a la que ahora se les
suma el rechazo al nuevo acuerdo con el
fmi para refinanciar un préstamo que
pidió el gobierno de mauricio macri en
2018 porque la situación social en
argentina se agrava a partir del ajuste
y el acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional que el gobierno ha firmado
estableciendo prioridades
y no son las del pueblo argentino según
cáritas y la universidad católica
nacional uno de cada diez argentinos
pasa hambre cotidianamente una situación
insostenible para muchos al menos 14
personas murieron y 31 fueron detenidas
en medio de un violento enfrentamiento
entre mineros registrados en la región
peruana de arequipa la fiscalía detalló
que los hechos ocurrieron en un aparente
intento de desalojo en una zona de
extracción de oro los 31 detenidos
permanecen en una comisaría para decidir
si entrarán en prisión preventiva los
primeros siete fallecidos en el ataque
que fueron localizados el sábado
murieron por heridas de arma de fuego
los otros 7 muertos aparecieron en el
fondo de un barranco
cambiamos de tema porque en batalla las
tropas ucranianas dijeron que lograron
avances en severodonezk pero advirtieron
que sin más artillería de largo alcance
no podrán seguir contrarrestando el
fuego de los militares rusos la lucha se
libra a casa a casa y bajo fuertes
bombardeos según el batallón de la
guardia nacional libertad de ucrania la
defensa aún controla la zona industrial
y las áreas alrededor de la urbe el
alcalde dijo que la situación es difícil
pero manejable entretanto el ministerio
de defensa de ucrania dijo que sus
fuerzas habían recuperado parte del
territorio en el área de gerzón en el
sur del país
los rebeldes separatistas en el este de
ucrania condenaron a muerte a tres
combatientes extranjeros que luchaban
para el ejército ucraniano se trata de
dos ciudadanos británicos y uno marroquí
anteriormente se habían declarado
culpables de los cargos que se les
imputaban entre ellos figuran terrorismo
comisión de un delito como parte de un
grupo delictivo y toma del poder por la
fuerza los hombres tienen un mes para
apelar la sentencia
un tribunal del estado ucrania
controlado por rusia ha condenado a
muerte a dos británicos y a un ciudadano
marroquí tras un proceso de tres días de
duración fueron capturados mientras
luchaban para el ejército ucraniano en
mariupol
y esperaba que la sentencia fuera mucho
más justa y teniendo en cuenta que ayude
a la investigación y también porque me
entregué a la república popular de
donets los dos británicos se entregaron
a las fuerzas prorrusas en la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol en abril mientras
que el ciudadano marroquí se rindió en
la ciudad oriental de bolt no baja en
marzo cada uno de ellos se declaró
culpable en diferentes tribunales de la
república popular de danielle los
separatistas les acusan de ser
mercenarios a pesar de que afirman haber
luchado junto a los militares ucranianos
moscú ha argumentado que los
considerados mercenarios extranjeros que
luchan por ucrania no son combatientes
regulares y por lo tanto no tienen
derecho a las protecciones concedidas a
los prisioneros de guerra una afirmación
muy discutida por los funcionarios
ucranianos y británicos
existentes
hopkins se trata de dos ciudadanos
británicos y han estado sirviendo en las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas mucho antes
de la invasión ilegal de ucrania por el
régimen de putin fueron capturados por
las fuerzas armadas rusas cerca de
mariupol y deben ser tratados de acuerdo
con la convención evra que es el derecho
internacional como prisioneros de guerra
un funcionario pro ruso de tony a es que
dijo que se les impuso la pena de muerte
como una forma excepcional de justicia
son los primeros combatientes
extranjeros condenados por los
separatistas ucranianos apoyados por
rusia y tienen un mes para apelar la
sentencia
inicio la primera cumbre amazónica de
periodismo y cambio climático allí
france24 conversó con alexandra narváez
ganadora del premio goldman 2022
considerado el nobel ambiental narváez
es indígena cofán de zinc and go' en la
amazonía ecuatoriana ella fue una de las
lideresas que logró que la justicia del
país cancelará 52 concesiones ilegales
de minería de oro así protegió su río
sagrado a guárico y resguardo las 32 mil
hectáreas de selva virgen en la que en
las que viven en las que vive su
comunidad maría clara calle enviada
especial a la ciudad de puyo le pregunto
cómo ha servido el reconocimiento
internacional que le dieron hace dos
semanas este este reconocimiento del
premio goldman
es una esperanza para poder cambiar
para fortalecer y es un paso más para
seguir en esta lucha porque esta lucha
no se acaba aquí contra las empresas
mineras esta lucha sigue y nosotros como
pueblo y nacionalidad cofán como mujer
también vamos a seguir aquí al frente
luchando y defendiendo pues en este caso
con el estado ya que el estado quiere
triplicar la minería y en donde va a
triplicar en nuestros en nuestro
territorio entonces nosotros vamos a
seguir aquí en pie de lucha y
defendiendo nuestro nuestro territorio
así finalizamos esta emisión de directo
américa a ustedes les agradecemos su
sintonía y los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros que ya llega la entrevista
exclusiva al presidente de paraguay
mario abdo benítez con natalia cabrera
enviado especial de france 24 a la
cumbre de las américas feliz noche para
todos
[Música]